[Musique]
c'est la rencontre avec les lecteurs ou
avec les futurs lecteurs donc de pouvoir
échanger et de pouvoir partager en
direct
avec des
personnes qui ont la possibilité de
s'identifier
ou de s'approprier l'histoire est le
thème que vous avez essayé de
décrire passé quelque chose de
d'une des plus grandes satisfactions
pour un auteur en fait
c'est l'histoire d'une passion dévorante
et qui va virer au cauchemar et cet
homme et cette femme vous êtes entraînés
dans une spirale infernale et on va se
retrouver dans la tête de l'abuseur
comme dans celle abuser j'ai voulu
vraiment qu'on pénètre l'univers la
folie et le déséquilibre aussi du bureau
[Musique]
c'est d'éveiller les consciences sur le
jugement
qui pour moi est très réducteur et
simplement de démontrer que 1 abusé
comme un abuseur
sont des êtres abîmé au départ de la
même façon et que
la plupart du temps un abuseur a été un
abuser